- Malgré tous les efforts
déployés pour promouvoir
l'activité physique, il faut se
rendre à l'évidence, le message
passe mal. Plus du quart de
la population mondiale ne bouge
pas suffisamment, soit la même
proportion qu'il y a 20 ans.
DENIS FORTIER, physiothérapeute
auteur de «Lève-toi et marche»
- Ce qui est intéressant,
c'est de voir que les pays
qui sont moins fortunés bougent
plus que les pays qui sont
plus riches. Encore une fois,
il y a un lien à faire
avec la technologie,
cette technologie-là qui
nous immobilise malgré nous.
- L'étude regroupe des données
de 2 millions d'individus
dans 168 pays. Résultat :
plus de 27 % de la population
mondiale ne fait pas 150 minutes
d'exercice modéré par semaine.
On observe parfois d'énormes
écarts entre certains pays et,
en général, un fossé marqué
entre pays pauvres
et pays riches.
- Dans les pays riches,
peut-être que les gens
sont un peu plus paresseux,
dans le sens qu'ils prennent
l'auto plus souvent.
- Ça m'étonne pas,
c'est tellement plus confortable
devant mon ordinateur ou devant
la télé ou devant mon livre.
- Une autre statistique
étonnante : les femmes sont
moins nombreuses à atteindre
le seuil minimal d'effort.
Dr MARTIN JUNEAU, cardiologue,
Institut de cardiologie de Mtl
- C'est comme ça dans presque
tous les pays du monde, on voit
une différence d'à peu près
10 % homme/femme. C'est vrai
au Canada aussi. Les différences
culturelles, probablement.
- Le Dr Juneau croit que l'étude
surestime le véritable effort
fourni par les participants, qui
ont répondu à un questionnaire
sur une base volontaire.
D'après Statistique Canada,
ce n'est pas 30 %, mais 50 %
des Canadiens qui ne font pas
assez d'activité physique.
- La seule chose qui est...
disons, identique dans l'article
du Lancet et nos données
cannadiennes, c'est qu'il n'y a
aucune amélioration ou presque
depuis le début des années 2000.
- Pour améliorer la situation,
il faudra faire plus de
promotion de l'effort physique.
- Je pense qu'on devrait mettre
beaucoup plus d'effort que ça.
On l'a fait, par exemple,
avec le tabagisme. Là,
on a déployé des gros moyens.
Qu'est-ce qui est arrivé?
Les niveaux de fumeurs
ont diminué de 10 %. Ça a eu
un effet sur la longévité.
- 10 % de citoyens plus
en forme, c'est précisément
la cible que s'est fixée
l'Organisation mondiale
de la santé d'ici 2025.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.